you know what
let's just uh you know
do the thing that we do y'all so welcome
back to Griffin with Griffin once again
here we go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wow
[Music]
what's up y'all ripping with Griffin
back again
I don't know why my damn title is not
showing up I'm just having one of those
mornings y'all it's you know I don't
know what's happening but there it is
anyways River with Griffin
Nick marks if you're into the Cog
Community uh got into a little bit of a
thing we're going to talk about that
Denver Nuggets won the NBA title gotta
talk about that more AI stuff every
single week There's new AI let's get
into all the news and notes
[Music]
all right anyways welcome back to
riffing with Griffin it's good to see
everybody once again thank you for being
here you know as always make sure you uh
oh not that one make sure you subscribe
hit that subscribe button uh that helps
you know you'll you'll find out when you
know
um what do you call it
when I'm actually going live and all
that kind of stuff so that's like
helpful uh you know it helps me to hit
the like button I need that like button
hit that's uh always you know
you know it's always helpful when you
hit the like button y'all so go ahead
hit that like button y'all hit it and
then
um what else what do we got going on
here twitch you know you guys know I'm
on Twitch I love twitch I hit me some
twitch daily so uh Eric Griffin gaming I
play a lot of Call of Duty but I've been
playing a lot of Diablo four never
played Diablo before love that game so
I'm streaming that a lot just you want
to be helpful help help to help me out
you know you can also be a patreon
member you could be a twitch subscriber
you could be a YouTube member all those
things the little that little bit a
month uh you know helps me keep the
thing going uh makes it worth my while
to keep doing it and for all you uh
super supportive fans I appreciate you
guys so you know welcome back to
Griffin with Griffin yeah you know I
just had the damn thing going and then I
forgot to there's a setting you have to
put to put it out live and I had the
wrong one so I didn't see what you were
seeing then I'd already tweeted things
out so I had to untweet put up an
Instagram again take the Instagram down
so all that stuff uh is uh you know
pretty crazy so thanks for being here
and all you people live I see you in the
chat thanks for being here I do read the
chat team at average
somebody that's a stupid name you know
how I feel about you guys stupid names
on the Internet is sure damn be your
damn name but anyways welcome back uh to
referral Griffin what a week uh you know
we just you had a regular week my car
was in the shop that's what happened to
me my car was in the shop I I um
the air conditioning wasn't working then
you know I had this electric car I got
this Jaguar i-pace it's a great car like
the car itself great the technology that
you know not so great but it's a great
car I gotta tell you that it is a great
car but what I realized too is like when
you have a warranty on a car like that
if you're getting one of these
newfangled cars or Tesla anything like
that uh you know keep the car within the
warranty but as soon as the warranty is
about to get get rid of it if you got a
three year four year warranty don't keep
the car past that I think that if you
can
you know not everybody can afford to
like you know do that but if you can
it's that's the time to trade it in and
get something new because technology is
moving so fast with uh electric cars by
the way too and I think that what we
really need is like electric hybrids so
like you have like a little bit of gas
in the car so you could go I mean the
future is going to be you could go 500
miles on an electric car and it's got
like a little reserve gas tank maybe
that like you could get oh I'm running
out of and then you could get to
wherever you need to get to to charge up
or whatever it is like that so that's
hopefully where the future is going but
it's me it's it's it's moving so fast
that like
there's who knows where it's going to be
so there's no point in buying an
electric car like if you buy a Tesla now
man in two years you're gonna be like
damn it's already going 800 miles or
whatever you know what I mean so anyways
so that's the situation with that so my
AC was uh
broken so uh I got my car back today big
hassle
um
what else happened this past week uh got
my new mattress got this Tempur-Pedic
mattress right but what I didn't know is
a Tempur-Pedic mattress has a smell so
when it comes out of the from the
factory so apparently they they put it
together
On Demand right at the factory they put
it in the box that foam with the plastic
it's got a very chemically chemical
smell and so Rachel's super sensitive to
Smells man like she opens the
refrigerator and if anything's even
feeling like she's like you know what I
mean she's just always been like that
super sensitive nose and so like this
and I I I'm sensitive to this smell too
so oh man what a hassle you gotta I had
to take the mattress cover off the
mattresses uh put your wash all that
stuff right and then put baking soda on
the mattresses put them outside on the
balcony let it sit because we got a twin
King right split King they call it you
know so we can like be different
positions
um and then you know and then put
everything back on put it still
it improved it but then I've been
Googling and looking into it and it's
just
um
you know it's just uh
it's just one of those things where you
have to you have to let it you have to
wait it out because I've I've asked a
bunch of people even in my gaming
channel a bunch of guys were like yeah
man we got a Tempur-Pedic oh yeah it
lasted a month it lasted two weeks so I
had to keep the door open so knowing
that it is going to go away is good
because man the bed is comfortable man
super comfortable you know what I mean
so shout out to Tempur-Pedic not that
this is like a
you know what you call it a Tempur-Pedic
ad but you know it is what it is
um oh by the way
um I'm going to uh Nashville so all you
guys if you're in Nashville area I'm
gonna be at the Zanies Nashville for one
night June 21st one night June 21st
come on out uh come on let's I want to
sell this out so I need you to tell your
friends if you know anybody in Nashville
if you're from Nashville just Nashville
people let's do this man come check me
out Nashville Zanies June 21st tickets
on my website ericgriffin.com and I'm
working on a new website actually by the
way so I've been talking to this person
and it's like it's going good so keep a
lookout I know you guys hate my website
at this point I've kept it just to be
stubborn because it's like a thing now I
like people talking [__] about it
but anyways and then for the weekend I
will be in Huntsville Huntsville so all
you Huntsville people come to stand up
live Huntsville is a great little town
so I hope all those people out there
want to come out and see me so come
check me out there in Huntsville so
all right before we get to the topics of
the day let's just go to some of the
let's go to some of the comments man
let's go to some of the comments
um this is from pork chop Express
68.90 Bobby could have just said Griffin
looks like Mr Potato Head it's like a
perfect look-alike I legit can't see Mr
Potato Head and not think of Eric
Griffin
yeah well you know I get it
just need some glasses I need like a Mr
Potato Head with a beard now so this is
a great cup shout out to Rick Glassman
and you can see where he gave it to me
maybe he'll use that
all right Shannon Greenlaw three two one
said thank you for this episode I'm 34
and it's so refreshing to hear my
favorite comedians being open and honest
about stuff from a guy's point of view
oh thank you for that you know sometimes
that's uh it's necessary uh then Blanca
Blanc 2069 love you and Wiggy oh I know
I haven't had Wiggy on in a while he's
just so busy man he's a big time
director you know he's always doing
music stuff and traveling and this kind
of stuff and it's like we don't live
close so it's hard you know to to we
haven't haven't really done that but I
still talk to Wiggy all the time shout
out to Wiggy he's a great dude really
great dude
um shy booty three two three
stupid ass name hey y'all I came here to
chill thank you for all your content
Eric keeps me happy and joyful as the
real world sucks but your content as
well as other comedians makes the world
a better place for me cheers thank you I
appreciate that kind of comment
um
of course now everybody that loves Matt
Rife keeps going to that Matt Rife
episode and now they're like this may be
four years later but I relate to Matt
I'm super picky too I'm a little older
than Matt six months and what he is
saying sounds just like me
I'm so down to dating him because we
sound so similar in what we want
him
oh my god listen you girls are so stupid
when you when you write this kind of
stuff when you send me messages you know
me and Matt really do you relate to the
handsome in-shaped guy with the [__] you
know what I mean
there's a lot of regular fat dudes that
feel the same way as him too but you're
not saying you know me and chubby really
relate to each other oh is that what it
is you relate to Matt you relate to him
uh this reminds me of when
I took this picture with Justin Bieber
Justin Bieber saw me at the Laugh
Factory right and then he like we talked
you know and he and he he was like we
took a picture together he put it on his
Instagram my Instagram blew up for six
months so many messages from girls from
boys not just oh my god um yeah me and
Bieber you know I think that we and him
and him and I would really get along can
you look us up really you think that's
how it works
you mean you he's your type you and 50
million other people out there 50
million plus probably think the same
thing like get out of my face man
all right uh jriver 6756 and this is
about my book club I want to do my book
club more often last week I talked about
Melissa f Olson her books this is a
series of like vampire books uh she
calls it the old world look her up man
it's really great books but somebody
else gave me a little thing here a
little context no no no uh where is it
the thief and the Beanstalk is a good
book I would love to see him uh a movie
made the thief in the beans talk I might
check that one out
um
somebody up Belinda Belinda cross street
said Eric you are so right about the
Bible just try to explain it to your
child as best you can and how you best
understand it if they ever ask you you
won't you won't be reading the Bible too
much uh too much gaming and kids will
never pick up the thick book like like
with no pictures and you know she goes
on because I was talking about like what
happened in Utah where they banned the
Bible uh they were in in protest to
Banning other things you know what I
mean
um what's going on with Matthew and the
Jen to jam podcast your guess is as good
as mine Matthew is such a busy dude so
we took a break to try to like regroup
you know because we didn't get the the
response that we wanted so we're trying
to figure out a new thing so look for us
in that all right but thank you guys for
all your comments and I'll I try to read
as many comments as I can but you know
you get it it is what it is
um
let's see where are we uh oh okay so
let's get into
um today's thing or the main thing I
wanted to talk about today is about
um I don't know if you guys are into
gaming and if you're not a lot of people
that are watching or probably into
gaming right now so anyways I play a lot
of Call of Duty and
um
there's a big time streamer big time one
of the big streamers in in the Cod
Community and just in the Gaming
Community his name is Nick Merks
so Nick Merks um you know he he plays a
lot of Call of Duty for like three years
I I found out about him through the
pandemic uh you know great dude like you
know he's like a doo doo you know what I
mean and when you're online like this
you kind of like your life is just
shared with the world it's a very
interesting thing you know like we know
he just had a baby got married you know
we kind of follow him he's into fitness
and gaming is a really good role model
for that kind of thing man you can you
know you don't have to sit there and be
a nerd gamer you could be like a cool
ass dude and game and have a real life
so he really represents the future of
what like what we're looking at here but
anyways he just had a baby too by the
way
um so there was some stuff that went on
there was a
of violent protest going on in front of
a school and it was uh so it was this
protesting LGBT and then it was pro-lgbt
people and they were having this thing
and there was videos about it and then
Nick Marsh tweeted basically they should
leave little children alone that's the
real issue and so
of course was in my opinion
people put their own context on it they
put their own opinion on it and they
made it a anti-lgbt tweet and then of
course in woke fashion Activision uh
because of whatever the the small like
loud minority on the internet that the
real cabal the you know the the real
Illuminati is this you know small
Twitter of population of people that
just talk loud they removed they this is
on the screen right now is his skin they
made like a skin for him for the game so
you could buy this skin and you could
play as Nick Merks in Call of Duty they
took it away
so in response to that you have other
famous streamers like uh Tim the tatman
or however say his name and of course
doctor disrespect they boycotted Cod
doctor disrespect went online live and
deleted Cod on his on his
um stream and he said he's calling for
people to not play Call of Duty anymore
until they apologize to Nick Merks okay
till they apologize to Nick marks so
let's go into
what I feel about this now I'm not going
to play Nick Mark's video but I looked
at his video and I encourage you to look
at his response video to this and it's
very thoughtful
you know and it's like and that's what's
missing is discussion
it's that's what discussion is missing
in the in the world right now man
um so Nick Merks
is now a father and he sees a video
where people are fighting in front of a
school and then there's all this you
know talk about what we should or should
not teach kids it's almost like that
they're trying to remove parents from
the equation and he responds with I
think they should the real issue is
let's leave the kids alone about these
subjects you know and also it could be
taken any which way it could be taken
like why are you fighting in front of a
school
um you know why are you talking about
this
to kids without the parents it could be
taken in many different ways but one
thing that it's not is anti-gay
and that's the thing that bug bugs me
about this
we what needs to happen is when someone
like this tweets that out
cod's response is a [__] response okay
this is like what a coward response hey
hey Activision's like we're good people
hey gay community don't worry we support
you we're good people and he's bad
that's not that if you think that's
better for society to have this
cowardice response
for the sake of money
everybody at that company should be
fired you are doing a disservice
to what
to the kids to that Community to this to
you this gamer who's been propping up
your game everyone involved loses
because of your cowardice
what should have happened in my opinion
to me
have a discussion about it you know
reach out to Nick marks and be like hey
let's discuss this hey Nick uh from
Activision can you be more clear about
what you were talking about that he
could have came on and said yes I sure
can and he could have done a video like
instead of it being a response video he
could have had the video that he had and
it could have been more positive just
like hey I'm a father now I think these
subjects should be talked about at home
um I don't think you should be fighting
in front of the school I don't think
this is a good representation of what we
like let's have a discussion so
immediately you jump to one side jumps
to his auntie gay the other side has to
be like oh no he's not and now what's
happened is there's a huge backlash
there's a huge population of people in
the country that feel like that this is
being jammed down their throat with no
context it's being jammed down their
throat with no with no like discussion
with no facts no information like we're
all the same you know like let's get
some like let's get some comment like
you there's no common sense in this
let's get some gay people to come out
and talk about this with like some
streamers Activision who are like maybe
they don't know anything about the gay
community and let's have people talk
about it there's plenty of people that
play COD who are gay there's plenty of
people who play you know what I'm saying
like this this doesn't make any sense to
like take this like narrow-minded stance
on either side now his Twitter is
blowing up so now what you've done is
you've galvanized all the real anti-hate
people all the real I mean all the real
haters all those people are like oh look
what you've done to Nick marks and now
they're gonna jump on thing and now he's
in a position where it's like he has to
come across like oh well wait a minute
now I'm not I'm not hater but all these
people are supporting him and now it's
like a fight that he's not even supposed
to be in dude just wants to game and be
a father
and now you turned it into something
that is not all because what what
because we can't really talk because you
think in 140 characters that represents
what people think that represents what
like that's their whole thought process
is this thing here
it's crazy
it's absolutely crazy and they 100
should apologize to him for this they
should apologize to both sides they
should be like you know what I believe
that we jumped the gun on this and we
should have probably had a discussion we
should have probably used this as an
opportunity to educate people how about
that how about we educate people on the
situation but now it turns into like it
has to be one or the other it has to be
your pro-gay or your anti-gay that's
what they've turned it into by their
cowardice response
for what the anytime these corporate
types come with this kind of response is
because they don't have the words to
articulate their position they don't
have the guts to come out and just talk
about it and then the other side stop
being so like you hate us you hate us
you hate us now now we we might hate you
because you being a [__] [__]
right now about this how about hey
people may not understand your lifestyle
and they don't have to
but you don't have to make it like
everybody's evil that doesn't get you
how about we just again let's just talk
let's talk
you know I think it's fair for parents
to be like whoa what are we teaching
what are we teaching our kids in school
right now is there an agenda here like
the perception is that this is being
forced on the educational system from a
very small minority of people and
everyone else is like whoa whoa can I
discuss the sexuality with my kids thank
you very much is that okay I I totally
get that I think that's a fair thing so
then it's like it should be like this
should be a discussion we should be
talking about the school board with
parents unions and
the LGBT whatever the other letters are
Community you know they should all be
getting together being like okay how
should we discuss this let's you know
what I'm saying like where what what's
happening right now what's happening
right now like Twitter to Twitter is not
the real world
why are we letting this [__] [__]
Place dictate what people think and how
we should function in society
it's like that's not a real place
that's not real thought it's not
complete thoughts
and by the way you're an idiot if you
look at someone's 140 characters and
think you know them or understand them
like what
if you're confused about something then
you reach out and be like hey to me this
I'm I I'm resp I think this means this
but I don't know for sure because I
don't know that person but no that's not
what people do somebody tweets something
somebody said something and immediately
put everybody puts their own context on
it as if they understand this person who
they are ridiculous
it's ridiculous okay
absolutely ridiculous
so
let's get back to like
that I mean school should be about I
don't even know anymore you know like
I'm thinking back to when I was in
school I took typing look this is how
this is how advanced how far school is
gone when I was in high school when I
was a senior in high school I took
typing typing I took typing in high
school typing think about that it was a
class math science PE
um you know
typing what was happening I'm thinking
back now thinking what the hell was
happening in the typing class did we had
a full class for typing like were there
lectures I hear the origins of the
lowercase j like what were we talking
about were we doing field trips to paper
mills like I just don't understand so
now you cut to I was taking typing to
we're teaching sexuality you know I just
I don't know
I don't know we have to figure this out
okay but we can't do it if we're divided
we can't do it with this sort of
divisive internet presence that isn't
taking into account
that these are real people Behind These
tweets these are real people out at that
protesting and they believe in what they
believe so let's like take a moment
let's step back have a discussion about
it as opposed to just firing off
and making rash decisions so I I uh I uh
I say a Activision Call of Duty you owe
Nick Merks an apology yes you do you owe
the gay community apology for this
pandering that you're doing that you
really think you care you owe them an
apology you owe the you owe your the fan
base an apology for even getting it to
politics in the first place
what are you doing you look stupid
let's discuss stuff okay
let's be open
let's try to have honest
that's like I said let's educate
and let's come together
because this [__] is not helping
anyone
all right
enough of that
okay y'all
um good stuff now I didn't talk you know
what I didn't talk last week about I
forgot to talk about the NBA I forgot to
talk about what I thought was happening
in the series and all that it was like
1-1 at the time and then cut to the
Denver Nuggets have won the championship
and I just want to talk about it now I
picked Miami and I really I didn't
wholeheartedly Pick Miami I just was
like how can we keep doubting Miami and
maybe they'll win in seven you know I
just was like let me pick the underdog
at this point because I couldn't believe
that uh what what I wanted the Celtics
to win because I wanted history I was
like wow this is great coming back from
3-0 for the first time ever I thought it
was gonna happen it didn't now the
eighth seed going to the uh Championship
you know I was like oh man playing game
team can win the championship I wanted
to see that history but it didn't happen
but let's talk about it first kudos to
the Denver Nuggets they were the best
team all year they had the best player
in the last three or four years in
yokich uh he just it's you know what and
I as I'm 6'3 and I went to a small high
school so I was a big man in high school
I went to big man camp when I was in
high school so basketball's a big man's
game okay when you get a big man who is
skilled it will be better than a little
man who is skilled because it's that's
the sport okay it's putting balls in the
rim and and pounding and rebounds and
defense he is I'm glad they're going
back to that just for me I like old
school you know what I mean and he's
gonna be dominant for a long time now
he's only in he's in his mid-20s so look
out for Denver Nuggets but so shout out
to them shout out to Jamal Murray for
coming back from his injuries coming
back from injuries like that and and and
to to win the championship
that's so awesome he was dominant in the
bubble he was scoring 50 points there
was that battle between Denver and Utah
and it was just fantastic then they went
on and played the Lakers and they lost
to the Lakers it was a younger LeBron it
was a younger A.D and you know LeBron
and A.D they gonna be better than Jamal
Murray and Jokers you know it's just it
is what it is and they went on to win
the championship in the bubble but it
proves that the Denver Nuggets were
right there you know they were right
there and so they improved they kept
working they got some uh Aaron Gordon
they got some uh role players they got
Kadarius Caldwell Pope came in all these
young players and they did it Mike
Malone great coach at the Denver Nuggets
but
if I had to say was this an all-time
great run no I don't think so okay they
played who they played the Lakers a
bubble team
like is where do they you know what I
mean they were a bubble team they had to
fight to get into the uh the playing
game they were a playing team and then
they they played Minnesota in the first
round playing team and then they played
Miami in the championship playing team
uh five years ago before the the playing
game none of these teams would have even
been in the playoffs think about that
none of these teams well I don't know it
depends if they were the eight seat or
not if they were any of them were
seventh and eighth they would have made
it so
even still
I mean the Lakers weren't the Lakers
were outside of it Minnesota was outside
of it and yeah and Miami was outside of
it yeah so they were none of them were
like the eighth seed actually they were
all 10 11 they were all 10 9 and 10
seeds you know what I mean so either way
it still was impressive it's hard to win
the championship so shout out to them
and on the other side Miami look Jimmy I
think Jimmy Butler's hurt I think I
don't think he recovered from his ankle
injury he just never looked the same
after that ankle injury when he missed
the game during the the first round I
believe it was and so he just never
looked the same after the 56 Point
performance he just never looked the
same they needed more maybe they'll get
one more superstar in my but hey you got
a shout out to Miami man they've been to
the championship twice in four years uh
Eastern Conference Final three of those
four years so
pretty impressive run it just came up
short the NBA I believe is in a really
good place hopefully LeBron James gets
one more Run next year maybe we see uh
um the Suns get their [__] together who
knows with Luca and and Kyrie and den
and Dallas or maybe maybe Kyrie goes to
the Lakers who knows we'll see what
happens I'm hearing Damian Lillard to
the heat you know or Damian Lillard
someplace where we could see some a good
Championship run so we'll see what's
going on with that and
um we'll see you know what I mean but uh
it was uh it was I enjoyed the playoffs
like I've been down on the NBA but this
playoffs really got me back into it so I
really enjoyed it and like I say Denver
look Denver's a great complete team this
is like a really great basketball team
and I'm glad that team won you know I'm
glad the team that drafted their players
and made made cool moves to get certain
pieces to help their Stars
play hard play defense win the
championship that's what I like I don't
always like it look I'm a fan of LeBron
James but I don't like how he's done it
in in in in some ways I don't like the
well let's join Superstars let's trade
for Superstars let's be top heavy and
see what we could do I don't like that
but by the way this Laker team that got
where they got I like this team better
than the the stupid team he built with
Russell Westbrook and and all the things
that happened there like this was a team
that was like oh okay they have pieces
you know what I mean the you know and
they and they they play good defense
like Austin Rivers it you root for a
team like that better than you root for
like the Suns for instance I wasn't
going to root for the Suns I was like
okay another team Kevin Durant's going
to and it's like uh I just wish that
that narrative would just go away you
know but he's gonna be 36.
so just look out look out for this man
LeBron James and Kevin Durant are going
to be at home a lot next year
they may play
maybe 60 games
that would be
a miracle
for Kevin Durant and LeBron James to
play 60 games next year
because
they're old
and their bodies have let them down they
play too hard
and their bodies are too old the two
things don't mix
Kevin Durant is a baller
and his body is just going to continue
to fail him so I just if he could play
82 next year oh I I hope it happens for
him I don't see it happening no one in
the history of the league ever has come
back from an Achilles tear like he had
that that particular injury
and be a hundred percent be themselves
especially at 36 years old so
we'll see
all right okay NBA talk
done all right
um let me see what's some other stuff
let me look at my topics here and thank
you for being in the chat love you all
and thank you for every other people
listening live that's been pretty great
um yeah here's some weird stories man
um
speaking of basketball we'll do this by
sticking with in the basketball world
because here's a weird story
it's not weird it's just funny so LeBron
James you know what a guy dude like he's
just gonna be that guy you know just
it's gonna be in the public eye forever
even after basketball but LeBron James
joins Taco Bell on a fight to free Taco
Tuesday phrase from trademark so shout
out to whoever the genius was that
trademarked the phrase Taco Tuesday I
don't know how they they were allowed to
do that it's like you could just
trademark any two words you know you
could just trademark you know will the
Beast Wednesday or I I don't know you
know Whataburger wins just what how can
people trademark he could have just just
move it to Thursday Taco Thursday you
know just I want to I bet you somebody
already has that trademarked in the
event somebody tries to do that so
apparently so you've seen those
commercials so apparently
um yeah it's been trademarked so I know
you guys saw that commercial
uh
uh there's like a commercial with with
LeBron James saying we're gonna free
this we're going to free Taco Tuesday
and I thought that they did but Taco
Bell announced last week that it filed a
legal petition via the USPTO trademark
trial and a board appeal to liberate the
phrase for restaurants Nationwide by
canceling the federal trademark
registration for Taco Tuesday
you know it's like so apparently like if
you are a restaurant you can't even use
Taco Tuesday
in like in your advertisements and you
got to pay like man it's like how much
money it's it's like any way people can
take advantage of freaking
um
you know what I mean anytime people can
take advantage of like
making money somehow taking the fun out
of life they do it I mean trademarking
Taco Tuesday is ridiculous to me
it's like the people that tried to
trademark happy birthday I think they
got rid of that finally like somebody
owned happy birthday and then you
couldn't sing Happy Birthday anymore
whatever without be having to pay
somebody it's like go [__] yourself you
know what I mean I'm singing Happy
Birthday
huh
thanks for the super chats by the way
speaking of making money light year
thank you he says Eric come to
Albuquerque you know I'll do what I can
Manny V Fondest Memories of cod was
gaming with you Griff what's up Manny
thank you for being here and Janine
every week this woman thank you so much
for your support
she said slow clap for free speech for
that oh so clap for that speech she said
yeah well you know I do what I do man
you know I I had to keep it raw and
honest that's why I do it live you know
what I mean so you got to like get watch
yourself I gotta make sure I'm not
I don't want to insult anybody I don't
want people to feel I don't want to
attack anybody well I don't even know if
that's true I mean sometimes I'd be
going in but you know some stuff that
should be public domain right
anyways getting back I just saw somebody
say that on the thing public domain
um so anyway that's just a weird story
so shout out to LeBron James we're
trying to fight for the little people
let's get back Taco Tuesday this is
liquid death don't worry I'm not
drinking beer
oh I love these I got a lot of messages
from people who were like man that ASMR
you were doing it made me turn it off
and I know there's other people that
felt the same it's like bye [__]
you know
you know my favorite thing about trolls
and chat is you guys think the world
revolves around you
it's so funny somebody will say Hey you
shouldn't do that oh I [__] it should I
not do that dude
there's a hundred million things to
watch on the internet I don't care if
you're here bye you don't want to hear
the slurps
ask me if I care
all right so let's go into some there's
some weird stories
uh this this one really like I don't
know how to feel about this one but this
is what an internet uh Instagram story I
only have one Instagram post today but
let's talk about this
how would you feel
a man fakes his own death and then
shocks his friends at Family by turning
up at his own funeral
what
this is this is a what
you me if my I don't know how I would
feel
let's say Bobby Lee did this because
this is some Bobby stuff
what if Bobby Lee
faked his own death
and then we're having a funeral you know
what I mean it's my turn to talk you
know I gotta I gotta make up some nice
things to say about him you know and
then he comes walking in the back hey
everybody look
I would beat his ass
okay
after of course I would be crying I
would hug him and then I would punch him
in the stomach and then we would do a
impromptu roast of him and everybody
that came up would get to slap him but
before they said something we would tie
him to a chair you know up at the
wherever we would this funeral is and
then we would walk by him and just just
smack his ass pow and then he'd be
crying you know what I mean and then you
know looking like a little anime you
know and then we could smack him and
then
talk about him this is really messed up
in my opinion this is really messed up
yes there will be a moment of joy
you know there's like a moment of joy
you would have and then the rest of it
would just be like how dare you do this
to me
how dare you right
this crazy uh this is just one of those
that's why I I'm talking about it right
now just so what do you guys think EV so
let me hear you in your comments on this
one if a person
your friend family member fake their own
death and then at their funeral they
showed up to be like I'm not dead
surprise what would you do
whoo
Mom I'm still thinking like well glad
we're already at a funeral because you
about to die
you did
we just put his dead body in the casket
we already thought he was dead anyway
right terrible
people are terrible dude
so that's that story right there
um what else is going oh and then this
is another one in the same vein of like
like you know so that's one somebody's
faking their own death right what if
this
um oh I hate all these stupid
commercials that pop up on the screen
well I guess it is what it is here we go
this one's another one that I found was
like how crazy is this a dead woman
found breathing in her coffin
she's at the hospital they pronounce her
dead
okay
they pronounce her dead
uh uh a hospital doctor in the city of
Bamba hey ho so that tells you all you
need to know about the medical system
and wherever the hell that is
me
well you can't even pronounce the name
of the city that the doctor's in that's
a sign right there
you need to get out of that place okay
so they thought she was dead after a
stroke she was placed in the coffin at
the funeral parlor where relatives held
a vigil when after about almost five
hours they opened the coffin to change
her clothes
and the woman gas for air
ah
but I had a little moment of silence
because I'm like what
first of all
I'm just thinking about all the feelings
you would have
let's start with the family
you already had to deal with
your mom's dead
they put her in the coffin
she at the funeral home
you're like my mom's dead my mom's dead
you know you you having a vigil you
talking about her people are crying
going through the morning process and
then you get her favorite dress like
let's get Mom's dressed you open up the
coffin and she's like you'd be like
I I don't even know what I would do just
that Joy you would feel right there but
shortly after that Joy
I would March down to the Boombah who
who Hospital
and beat this doctor's ass
right
I would you would go get him you and
your like criminal cousins and that one
Uncle who just got out who know people
you would grab that doctor
put him in a coffin and close it and let
his ass sit in there for five hours
okay and then you let him out and go you
need to retire [__]
you're you're your doctor days are done
because look what you did
how Furious would you be now
imagine
you in a coffin
you went to the hospital you're oh you
don't get a husband you wake up
you in a coffin
thank God when they opened it is when
she woke up gasped her ear imagine
well I guess maybe they would have heard
her their individual unless they had
music playing or something
oh but what if she'd woke up like
you know that's throwing dirt on the oh
my God I just I'm having chills thinking
about
that the timing of this could have been
terrible they could have never known how
about this what if this dumbass doctor
has done this before like I'm thinking
about it now they need to like dig up
every person that they that he has said
is dead in the last year
do our top autopsy on these bodies to
find out when the time of death actually
was oh my God imagine
if someone was buried alive just think
about that for a second
imagine being buried alive
he
I'd rather have a shark eat me from my
feet first
then being buried alive
I don't know what to say about this
story but that's terrible and I hope in
wherever they are the day can sue this
dude doctor need to be sued okay food
ah
unbelievable
I mean what an unbelievable story right
all right guys and lastly let's get back
to and here's like you know we've been
talking a lot about AI
and
dude there's here's some weird AI news
here's in the in the AI world
you know I don't know if this is a
positive or negative but apparently
Paul McCartney on Tuesday said that an
AI was used to extract lent John
Lennon's voice from an old demo and used
in this song
a unreleased Beatles song that maybe
they were working on so they the AI is
using his voice
and they're putting out this song and
you know what AI singing in John
Lennon's voice so you know it's going to
be perfect pitch it's gonna be like
I don't know how to feel about this how
do you feel about this man you know I
mean this is
um
this is crazy you know I'll tell you
what's crazy about it is like what we
appreciate about art
you know like what is the thing that you
personally appreciate about art so
you know you take a person
like
Mariah Carey you know
and here's this human being with this
spectacular voice and then you know
you're listening to it and you
appreciate what do you appreciate you
appreciate the beat the music the
musicality the harmonies do you
appreciate her voice do you appreciate
the fact that oh this person can sing
like this and no one else can and that's
what you appreciate about it that's what
you like about it like actually think to
yourself what do you like about your
favorite song what do you like really
think about this and I'd love to see
your comments in the comment you know
comment on this please what do you like
about your favorite song your favorite
artist what do you like about them when
you hear the song is it because it's
them you know you take someone like
Chris Brown for instance
oh God I hope we're not gonna get into a
controversy about that I'm just saying
the dude is a ballerina the guy can
really dance he can really dance like
that guy if you see him live it's
incredible to watch that guy dance he
can dance he can sing and then you say
you got so what do you like about a
Chris Brown song is it the Beats is it
to you know is it that you he's
performing it uh his voice then when you
see it live is it dancing like you know
anybody think about Whitney Houston when
she was alive she had this spectacular
voice and so is that what we liked about
it like what do you like about the
person that whatever it is what now what
we're saying is
AI can do it
so
what is there to appreciate about this
is it just going to be about the music
now
is it just going to be about like what
do we like about this so if they can
take I get it for someone dead like in
this instance it's like hey here's a
song that we didn't release
and it's kind of like it's kind of like
when
you know they they put out those Frank
Sinatra albums where they he's dead or
remember when Natalie Cole made an album
of songs with her father and they just
took his recordings
and
they sung and she sung with her father
and we were like oh that's really cool
honoring her dad using the old
recordings
they did this with Biggie Smalls the
Notorious B.I.G they did this with
Biggie Smalls you know rappers were
rapping with him you know uh with old
recordings you know and so we're like Oh
okay that's cool that they did that but
now ai
a new Biggie album can come out
right maybe they have a notebook of his
they hear some raps that he was going to
come out with before he died
and then they go they put it in the AI
AI learns his Cadence and everything and
now a new Biggie album comes out from
his diary and they call it the the Diary
of Biggie Smalls whatever right how do
we feel about that how are we honor are
we honoring him or at this point it's
like are people pulling a fast one on us
it's a really tricky area it's like a
new area of things what if like I'm it's
not me doing this podcast live what if
I'm like okay uh AI learns me my my
mannerisms and I go all right I want you
to talk about this this and this today
go live Ai and it's not even it's the
Max Headroom you know and it's the AI
Eric going like Hey Y'all what's up the
woo-woos are always perfect you know
what I mean you'll be like oh it
woo-boo's on point today what's going on
with Eric and his woo-woos and it's
because
the AI is doing it
like this is
crazy man
you know what I mean it's like a crazy
um it's a crazy thought process man
to to think about because
how we are going to appreciate art will
change
think about a photograph someone takes
think about a painting think about you
know we yeah listen some of the greatest
artists of all time for longevity's sake
have long been dead man like Beethoven
Chopin
like you young people don't even know
what I'm talking about but if you think
about it Beethoven ha it has lasted
longer five or six times longer than
than you know some of the artists that
you like that you may have liked or
maybe even from my childhood Beethoven
lasted longer than MC Hammer you know
what I'm saying think about that longer
than say even like a great per like
Cyndi Lauper or like think of somebody
that you thought was like great 10 20
years ago Beethoven has lasted longer
than them what I'm saying is
how we now appreciate art
if
it's not being made from
the human brain
like this is the Crux of what the writer
strike is about what the actors will
strike about where it's a matter of like
these studios are like hey we don't even
need you we don't need writers we don't
need actors you know we we have we have
CGI technology and a computer that could
do just as what you do what are we gonna
do
we already we already complain about
auto-tune right we already complain
about like oh you're not really singing
That's Auto-Tune uh you know they're
fixing your voice in the studio and when
you go live you can't sing
now the the the the AI
the AI version of your voice
it's perfect
how
are we going to appreciate art then
moving forward
how
so
I don't even know it's a really
fascinating question and thing to think
about man is what do we do moving
forward like I really want you to answer
that question for me because I'm gonna
think about it too why do I appreciate
art
can you answer that question guys and
girls men and ladies
can you can you answer the question like
pick an artist that you like and tell me
why you like them
pick a song pick a painting that you saw
what is it about it you know when people
do art appreciation
like what is art appreciation classes
now like an art history major what is an
art history major gonna do moving
forward in the AI world
are we gonna then have to appreciate
what the AI made are we going to be like
looking at this like oh this AI found a
way to really mimic this or it's is it
like new levels of appreciation that's
gonna come
yeah that's I see somebody talking about
how you singers use pitch correction
that's what I'm saying so what I'm
saying is that's what I mean and we look
down on that or do we only care that the
song sounds good and we're moving
forward or that our appreciation for
this artist is that they don't need that
stuff and this is what they're doing but
now what we're saying is albums will
come out you know singers will come out
and they'll be just like
it won't be them at all
so you could just grab random hot person
fake AI voice they will go on to make
Never sing live they'll find a way
because they won't have to because they
could just be on the internet the whole
time
and do we care will you care
at what point will we be like oh
now I just appreciate
like I need to hear Bad singing
to know that it's human but maybe the AI
can even mimic that uh I don't know man
it's it's like I'm blowing my my own
brain is blowing up right now just
thinking of all of the uh
the implications of this
so let's discuss it all you regulars new
people thanks for being here
um make sure you uh you know check me
out ericgriffin.com a game you know what
I mean I'm always gaming I'm again I'm
gonna be gaming after this in a little
while you know but hey hit the subs hit
the Subscribe button for me man
subscribe so you know and hit the
notifications thing so you know when
it's coming and like I said I'm on
Twitch all the time so make sure you
check me out make sure you check me out
there on Twitch
uh because that's like where I do and if
you want to support me on patreon you
could be a patreon member a sub on
Twitch you could be a YouTube member any
which way you go hey man I want to
support you financially I love what
you're doing and I want you to keep
doing it you know I would I would
appreciate that greatly too guys you
know what I mean so once again thank you
for listening to Griffin with Griffin
and you know what time it is
oh yeah
it's that Rob recap
here on Wilson Griffin
[Music]
I don't know who it is
it the real person singing
computer program winning
tell you about
[Music]
trademarking that's wax
foreign
[Music]
on a rap recap if you want to send me a
beat if you're a producer just make sure
it's not copyright and send it to Eric
griffin.com I'm gonna be at Zanies in
Nashville June 21st and then check me
out in Huntsville for the weekend
thank you y'all thanks for being here
and I'll see you next week
[Music]
thank you